the legendary creator of akira katsuhiro
otomo has created an animated
masterpiece three short stories woven
together as a sequence of memories today
we're going to talk about the second
part of the memories an episode called
stink bomb it's a satirical story about
a chemical researcher who is merely
seeking a solution to get rid of his
cold but why is everyone around him
dying let's dive into the film story to
find out what it's all about the film
begins with the picturesque views of
yamanashi and then the scenes
immediately shift to the waiting area of
a doctor's clinic swamped with patients
some of them are recurring patients it's
revealed that there's a flu outbreak in
the city the patient inside the doctor's
room is getting a flu shot by the nurse
the doctor recommends watching out for
his symptoms and that the shot would do
the trick he writes him a prescription
for the entire week the next patient who
walks inside has the flu too apparently
that year's flu breakout is bigger than
ever this man who just got his shot gets
dropped off at a lab he's nobuo a lab
technician battling the flu just like
any other person in the city nobody
decides to go back to the lab despite
the fever because he doesn't have
anything to do back at home and no one's
there to take care of him either nobuo's
colleague warns that he might set off
the biocon alarm if he sneezes too much
and suggests testing out the company's
over-the-counter cold medication maybe
take them all at once nobody has been
taking them but they're not helping
another colleague suggests he should try
the new medication the company is
working on since its samples are present
at the chief's desk two blue pills in
the red bottle should take care of the
flu
noble pays a visit to the chief's office
to show him some papers but he doesn't
find him there desperately trying to get
some relief he tries to find those pills
he reaches for the blue bottle since it
says samples and decides to take just
one of those red pills yeah you may have
taken the wrong ones two girls are
having a chat when they smell something
like perfume the chief comes out of his
office into the hall and starts yelling
he's found out that someone has stolen
the red pills the same colleague who
suggested nobody take the pills ended up
revealing that nobuo went inside the
office and took some of the samples upon
hearing this the chief gets even more
furious and asks where nobuo is they say
that he wasn't feeding well so he went
to the reception to take a nap the chief
reveals that it wasn't fever medication
and rushes to the reception to see how
nobuo is doing now others can smell
something unusual too nobuo wakes up
from a slumber feeling refreshed and
notices like it's morning and nobody
woke him up he steps into the hallway to
check and finds one of the girls
sleeping on a desk oh no it looks like
she's dead and it's not just her
everyone in the lab is dead even the
rats in the cages panicked by the site
he calls an ambulance he enters the
chief's room and finds out that he's
also dead it looks like the chief turned
off the biocon alarm but why would he do
that nobuo turns on the alarm and learns
that an incident has happened he's
connected to a video conference with
some folks who thought they related to
the chief and are surprised to see
someone else on the screen they're
asking for our maida the person in
charge the webcam rotates and the people
on the other end of the line are stunned
to find the boss on the floor nobuo
tells the man that everyone in the
facility has ended up like this and he's
not quite sure when all of this happened
and for how long nobody gets yelled up
for calling the police in the ambulance
none of them have shown up in this time
though he's asked to find a medication
and certain papers and bring them to the
tokyo headquarters the man behind the
screen is goichi ninasaki the head of a
new medicine development he's also
instructed not to give the medicine and
papers to anyone but him and tells him
to keep that accident discreet and to
not tell anyone that he works for the
company since all of this has something
to do with the pills the government
can't know anything about that mission
which is why he must find the papers and
medicine samples and get out of the lab
before the police find him the pills
happen to be part of a biological
weapons program being developed for the
government while people are dying
there's a strange view outside cherry
blossoms and sunflowers have bloomed at
the same time all plants in kofu city
are blooming the helicopter with a bunch
of reporters in the air is able to spot
a survivor it's none other than nobuo
swinging a flag to get their attention
as soon as they approach him the
repelling smell gets to them and they
fall down nobuo unaware of what's
happening uses the camera to call for
help garmada the president of nishibashi
pharmacy and the head of development
nirasaki explain everything to the
japanese military and that they're
trying to get data from chief omada's
computer to figure out how potent the
pill is the wind carrying the odor is
spreading the authorities think it's a
poisonous gas but they have yet to
determine what's causing it it takes a
while for kamata and nirasaki to figure
out that the only survivor nobuo is the
cause of the gas the men from the
military spot nobuo and try to approach
him to rescue him but they die from the
odor too it's clear to everyone that
nobuo is the stink bomb the officials
quickly withdraw from the scene no boy's
family sees him on tv asking for help
the head of the research company on the
other hand deduced that nobuo took the
pill and now he's a big threat to
everyone the sweat produced by his body
due to overwhelming emotions and body
movement is the reason why he stinks the
military wants him dead but others who
invested in the research want him alive
dozens of tanks helicopters and fighter
jets chase after nobuoa his grandmother
speaks on a loudspeaker from the
helicopter and tells him not to go to
tokyo then suddenly one of the soldiers
shoots at nobuo after trying to escape
he gets attacked by a huge number of
fighter jets tanks and even battleships
the missiles destroy roads bridges and
even houses he's on a scooter and oddly
enough he dodges all of the attacks
effortlessly it turns out that the
chemicals on nobuo's oda are causing
interference on the targeting systems
the rockets start going in the wrong
direction so the military's plan to kill
nobuo goes south
orders are given to evacuate tokyo at
this point there's chaos throughout the
city the traffic is jammed the airports
are crowded and the prime minister is
planning to release a statement asking
the un for help kamatar and nirasaki are
ordered to escape from the scene the u.s
military who've been watching the
situation up to this point takes over
the mission and sends in a nasa squad of
three soldiers in super powered space
suits to try to catch nobuo who they
wanna live
nasa's latest spacesuit is a prototype
which can repel electromagnetic
radiation and can help capture nobuo
alive nobuo scooter's given up and he
can't figure out why he's so hungry all
the time unaware of the mission the
japanese army destroys a section of the
bridge to prevent nobu from fleeing
locking him in a tunnel while using
liquid nitrogen wind repulsion devices
to try to freeze him meanwhile the nasa
squad wearing the prototype suits arrive
at the scene and try to approach the
stink bomb noble is frightened to see
these men but at this point he's got
nowhere to run
they managed to put him successfully
inside the isolation bag and drag him
back to the military headquarters in
tokyo one of the nasa soldiers brings
the suitcase full of documents and the
sample appeals to mr nirasaki after the
soldier presses the button on his suit
and one of the protective layers of his
helmet is removed they find out that the
person inside the suit is nobuo and he's
still completely unaware to the fact
that he's the cause of the biological
pollution he ejects himself out of the
exosuit killing everybody in the
facility
the end the film left us with so many
questions and we're sure you've got a
bunch of them yourself i mean how did
nobody make it all the way into the
command center without anybody noticing
him why didn't they make him take off
his costume before letting him in or at
the very least remove the tint why
hadn't it occurred to him that the odor
was actually coming from him all along
do you know the story for stingbomb is
based on an actual event it may be
referring to the gloria ramirez incident
causing toxic death tensai okamura
injects a much needed comedy into
memories lightening the tone and
throwing something completely unexpected
at the audience the dark humorous
moments paired against the all too real
sights of a viral outbreak add to the
overall feel of this one-of-a-kind
composition the main protagonist
fumbling antics as he thwarts the
government and army's advances never get
old and they always contribute to the
story's absurdity quotient stinkbomb is
a fantastic addition to this collection
of stories and one that you'll remember
for a long time if you enjoyed this
video be sure to check out the other two
stories part one and three of memories
for more videos like this follow our
channel and get updates about every new
video